hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our daily homeroom
live stream for those of y'all who are
new uh this is something that we started
doing
it feels like a lifetime ago now almost
two and a half months ago uh when we
started seeing school closures and we
realized that you know it's our duty as
a not-for-profit to step up even more
and figure out how we can not only keep
people learning but how can we stay
connected in this time of social
distancing so this is just a place to
have interesting conversations about
education about the crises in the world
and anything else and we have a very
very exciting guest today but before we
get to our guest i'll make my standard
announcement reminding everyone that
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization uh we can only exist due to
philanthropic donations we were running
at a deficit even before the covid
crisis and you can imagine with our
usage being two to three x of normal and
we're trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs uh to keep all of
y'all learning to support teachers and
parents and uh to support everyone as we
go to this very uh unusual back to
school that we're likely to face
the only reason why we're able to do
that is with support from folks like
yourself i do want to make a special
shout out to several corporations that
have stepped up
bank of america google.org att fastly
and novartis all stepped up in the last
few weeks and this is above and beyond
the many other philanthropists corporate
partners foundations that have supported
khan academy through the years that have
put us in a position to be able to
support folks through a crisis like this
so thank you to all of them but we are
still running at a deficit and there's
still a lot that we could do
and so if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating so with that
said i'm excited to introduce our guest
stu schmill who's the dean of admissions
and financial student financial services
at mit stu welcome
thank you sal nice to see you
yeah you know i i when i when you when
we had you on the guest list i'm like
what are we going to talk about there's
nothing interesting going on
in college admissions or testing or
colleges it's just all same same same as
always right
yeah it's been very uh very boring and
even uh nine to five uh come home and
that actually it's not even come home
anymore
all right you're home stay home you
don't have to go yeah it's all it's all
from looks like your attic in your attic
room uh no no in all in all seriousness
obviously
a lot has obviously uh if the sarcasm
wasn't super obvious to anyone a lot has
obviously been going on in the world i
don't know maybe tell me from your
vantage point um
you know how has it evolved how's your
thinking evolved what are you seeing
from students what are their concerns
and and just how do you see
this coming back to school changing or
evolving for for a place like mit
yeah so i think um
this uh
the pandemic while it had been building
for some time over the beginning part of
this year
i think really
took hold in our minds in terms of
changes that we were going to need to
make
over the course of this spring
relatively quickly
really get to the end of february
beginning of march
and we made some very very quick
decisions
on uh what our education was going to
look like
this spring
and um
universities are not always or haven't
always been known for very quick
decision making
um
and i was actually very impressed with
uh the speed uh at which we were able to
carry out uh some of the changes that we
did but also
um very impressed with i know certainly
the people on on on my campus at mit and
i think this is true universally
is how
much we kept the student at the center
of all of the decisions that
were being made
and tried to make decisions that were in
the best interest of the students
and um so certainly the decision to send
our students home or at least those that
were able to go home those who would be
safer from a health point of view
home
sending them home very quickly was
really in their best interest
standing up uh continuing our education
along in online fashion
very quickly
also trying to ensure that students had
the ability to continue
to make progress towards their degree
but also there were students that had
very particular circumstances so right
now there are still a few hundred
students undergraduate students who are
living on the mit campus because it's a
better environment for them
uh than uh anywhere else that they might
have been able to go to and um
so um
really a lot of the uh decisions that
have been made
were really made with the students at
the center of this and i know going
forward because the last few months
we've been planning on what's going to
happen up
as we get near the fall and
maybe you or others might have questions
about that
as we go along here
we're also thinking about what is going
to be best for our students and our
entire community um both from a health
point of view and then educationally
and what do you see the scenarios i know
i mean i'm eager to talk about how even
admissions has had to evolve or might
have to evolve going forward but just
your vantage point in the university
itself what are the contingency plans
you're hearing about for this coming
back to school
well um we certainly know that
with whatever happens and whatever
decisions that are made by colleges and
universities around what their
educations are going to look like it's
going to look very different than it did
last fall
um the virus is still going to be with
us
and um it's still very contagious and
you have to be very careful about
um
uh very dense environments
and universities are very dense
environments and um i think uh we along
with many other or really all colleges
and universities
acknowledge and recognize that
online or rather in-person education is
extremely valuable
and we want to see students come to
campus
we just have to be able to do that in a
responsible way and what that will
ultimately look like
is not yet clear
it's not clear that we'll be able to
have all of our students back on campus
or some of our students on campus or
and where that line is uh is drawn
so i think that
regardless of ultimately what happens it
will be different
because even if students are on campus
there will be different expectations for
what we'll be able to do
um
in terms of living in the dorms we'll
have to be a little bit less dense
perhaps than we have been in the past
in the classroom will have to be less
dense there will be
guidance around
or guidelines around
social distancing and wearing face
coverings
will there be parties and sporting
events and all the rest of that
we're not going to be able to have the
same kind of
large event
programming
that colleges
uh are
well in some cases famous for certainly
uh but
it's one of the things that students
really love about college so those
things are going to change a little bit
in the fall
and what are you hearing from the the
class that you just admitted the people
who would be freshmen you know i'm
hearing in the general press a lot of
students thinking about well you know
freshman year maybe i i take a year off
or i take a gap year how accommodating
are you all of that type of thing or and
how are y'all advising students who are
thinking that through
yeah so students uh right now we're
getting a lot of questions students want
to know what's going to happen
i think most everybody
is
really hoping that they're going to be
able to come to campus
in the fall we're hoping the same thing
so we're getting a lot of questions
about that and we have had students ask
us
uh or say that well look if i can't come
to campus
in the fall then
i may take a gap year or i may defer my
uh enrollment
thing about that is um i think students
are saying that without
really even knowing well what are their
other options going to be so take a gap
year
to do what
so that's not clear
and also
i think students
particularly new students
are thinking
uh well either on campus and if it's not
on campus they're thinking that the ex
that the
online experience
that we may be able to offer in the fall
is going to be like
what their online experience
has been in high school
and i don't think that's true um in fact
i know that our faculty
and many of our other instructional
professionals are working very hard to
ensure that
any of the online
tools that we have
for teaching students are going to be
really very high quality and
and very different than what students
have seen and experienced
this spring
and
i think in any scenario even one
scenario where students are on campus
there's going to be some online learning
uh that will be happening particularly
again because uh we have to limit the
size of classes etc so i think the
quality of that online instruction is
going to
improve
um and so students are
i don't think they have enough
information yet to know
uh whether they really do want to defer
their enrollment or not
for our part at mit
we're going to be
very open and essentially let students
make the decision as to what they think
will be best for them
once they have all the information as to
what our fall program is going to be
like um but i don't know how universal
that will be i think um
there are a lot of uh considerations
uh that
colleges and universities will have
around how many students that they can
allow
and afford to let defer for a year
mit happens to be in a relatively
privileged uh position uh there that um
you know we we can withstand that
from a financial point of view
no it's fascinating and i mean well we
could talk more especially if people ask
questions and just remind everyone if
you have questions and a lot of
questions have already started to come
in on facebook and youtube please ask
them but i think that's a whole other
dimension of it sounds like the places
like mit are going to be they're going
to be able to weather the financial
storm of this but there's a lot of
colleges and universities that were
already kind of on the fence pre-covered
and this might put them over so that's a
whole other interesting topic
one question just because there's been
so much in the news lately i'm sure you
are aware you know the university of
california system yeah really kind of
stimulated by covid they're like look
for the next couple years s.a.t will be
sat and act will be optional and then
they've essentially
it's not testing optional they've
essentially said two years three years
out they're not going to consider
something like the sat places like
university of chicago we had jim nandorf
on the show i guess that's what we can
call it a show
they're testing optional they still have
ninety percent of their students take
the sat do i think those that they're
admitted how are you thinking about it
and you know there's several questions
from facebook you know agambathya what's
the process of judging an application
applicant in context i think that's you
know people hear that so what's your
view on these standardized tests and how
do you put them in context
yeah by the way big fan of jim nondorf
and i think what he's done at the
university of chicago has been great in
terms of the way they've approached
their uh testing because that works for
them um and i think generally the
conversation around testing nobody loves
testing very or very few people i love
testing i'm kidding
yeah
well there are people who do i i know
there are people
and um uh and in fact you know i know
when i was in high school i wouldn't
necessarily say the sat was the thing
that i love to take but i you know went
through the the math competitions and uh
and loved all that stuff so so there are
students out there who do but by and
large people don't love testing and i
think what people really um acknowledge
is that a test
that um is so high
and
uh therefore stressful and
pressure-filled uh that determines so
much for a student
um that that's not good and i think we
would all agree that um you know sitting
for one test shouldn't determine
a student's pathway going forward
and also people look at the tests and
they see that there are disparate
outcomes
so
low-income students students of color
tend to have lower scores on average
and um and so you know there's there's a
sense that there's some unfairness
in that
um
so my take on this with mit though is
that um the tests uh the sat the act
really are
one and really the only consistent
measure of some academic
uh output that students can offer
we have students applying to us from all
over the world but even in the united
states there's such a diversity of
k-12 systems the high schools in the u.s
and and we're not familiar with all of
them
and um
so those standardized tests are
the only real consistent academic
measure that we have
and we also find at least we research
is that the tests are the best predictor
of success in our curriculum
and mit
uh right from day one
uh is a pretty challenging place
and we want to make sure that any
student that we admit
is going to be academically ready and
prepared
to do that work regardless of where they
come from
and
the tests give us that confidence to be
able to
uh
admit students knowing that they're
going to be successful
and the tests give us that confidence in
ways that grades alone do not
um and so uh for us the tests play a
role they are not uh the only thing that
we consider
we also are fully aware as i mentioned
earlier that there are
uh you know different groups that will
perform differently based on resources
and in fact you know family income is
maybe the best predictor of a student's
sat score
all that said we're aware of that and
we're aware of that in the admissions
process
um and so you asked a question or one of
one of our listeners asked a question
about what does it mean to
uh do college admissions in context
and what that means is really
understanding
the environment
the opportunities and the resources that
students have had
um and making an evaluation of their
talent and their potential based on
where they come from and how they've
performed in their context you know one
way to think about this
is um you know imagine two runners
racing
and people think that okay that's fair
you line up two people
and you let them run and whoever gets to
the the finish line first
is a faster runner
but um you also have to consider the
fact that
um
the the two runners may be running under
under different conditions
one may be running into a headwind while
the other has a really strong tailwind
and if you really want to judge the
talent and the potential of those
runners you have to understand
the environment the headwinds the
tailwinds that they may have in order to
make those fair assessments
so that's what it means to do admissions
in context is understanding
uh the environment or the headwinds
that students
makes a ton of sense and just more
tactically short term because some of
the testing administration dates had to
be pushed back some of the tests got
cancelled here there how are you all
thinking this is a question uh arnov
sawat from youtube uh what about sct and
act for this coming admission cycle how
are you all thinking about that
well we know that it's possible that uh
students may not be able to um have
access to tests that's possible and if
that's true we'll adjust
our uh admissions process
my admissions process takes in
quite a number of inputs so the test is
just one of many many inputs that we
have
and um we like to have it because as i
mentioned earlier it's helpful for us
but if we don't have it we can still
make decisions
uh using the best information that we
have
from the rest of the application and um
you know we haven't uh made or set or
changed our policies for next year as a
number of schools have quite a number of
schools have said that they are for next
year going to be test optional
um in anticipation of the fact that many
students won't have access to the tests
and that may come to pass
but we're waiting just to see how things
develop in the fall in the hopes that
there will be some ability for students
to to be able to take those tests
that make makes sense and you know one
question this is you know from youtube
lauren crowd does mit measure the
passion a student has in the area they
are applying for and i'll just add to
that you know there's kind of these two
schools of thought and admissions one is
is kind of what you hear word or mouth
and a lot of especially i would say
competitive high schools where there
seems to be institutional knowledge but
there you know there's a lot of kids
joining tons of clubs taking
a ton of um ap courses you know they
might be taking the sat or the act three
four you know i've heard horror stories
even more more times than that um you
know and there's this kind of
stereotypical application and these kids
are kind of in this pressure cooker
environment they're kind of check boxing
that's one school of thought but then
whenever you talk to an admissions
officer they're like no no no no that's
missing the point we care about you know
your whole being we want to see people
who have a passion in one or a few areas
who have this potential so
you know and then i think the people
that first school thought say oh well
they just say that you know that's kind
of the correct thing to say but they
really want us gunners so so
clarify what's the truth yeah
so the truth really is um is the latter
that we really we i'm going to tell you
what all admissions officers have been
telling you for years
and that's the truth
that is the truth and the reason why it
gets confused well here's here's the
reason why it gets confused is because
students and parents
make judgments
on very few data points
and in fact data points that they don't
even
know
fully
they see
they see who gets admitted
to our schools
and
they make assumptions about why they may
have been admitted to our schools
it's never
the
volume
or the quantity
of uh
what a student does
it's never that it's always
um
you know who they are as a person
their talent really their match
with our mission
um you know for mit of course we're a
school that is centered on science and
technology so we like to see that
interest
but we're also a place that's trying to
make the world a better place in fact
right in our mission statement to apply
science technology and other areas of
scholarship
uh to best serve the nation in the world
in the 21st century
and we're looking for students who we
think are going to resonate with that
mission
and if all you are is cranking away
loading up on activities and advanced
classes and all the rest of it
it's very hard in fact i think students
do themselves a disservice when they do
that
because they don't leave themselves time
to cultivate their interests
and to think about how they can make an
impact on their communities we actually
pay attention to that you know how much
are students helping the people around
them
um and i think if students are just
uh flat out and and
on overload
um they really do themselves a
disservice because they they're they
can't put the the time and the the
mental energy into the things that
really are interesting to them and
develop those talents more fully
and how do you discern that i mean to
the question from lauren you know how do
you how can you separate or you know
folks who are maybe even very
sophisticated at applying you know maybe
there's obviously cases of consultants
some of which obviously famously have
been illegal uh where you know these
perfect applications versus kids who are
truly authentic about those passions and
they would have had those passions even
if they weren't trying to get into a
selective university
right so again i mentioned earlier we
get inputs from a range of places so on
the academic side you know the test
scores the grades and there are other
ways that students can demonstrate
academic talent ability
uh we ask students to write essays uh to
tell those uh about themselves
and and and actually i think while yes
there are consultants out there and and
students can basically tell us anything
they want to
we generally trust that students are
are speaking from the heart when they
write those essays but we also get
letters of recommendation
from teachers and counselors in schools
and those have to align
and and teachers and counselors
often do a pretty good job at describing
who the students are and we make sure
there's some alignment there
we also offer an interview although
that's um not every student has access
to the interview but many many do and
and the interview can shed more light
um in ways that are harder to game
and uh we think that um
we are able to discern
when students are being authentic
you know um
it's so interesting to me
that um
after we admit students in a given cycle
and i have the opportunity to meet with
them when they first come on campus
so many of of them come up to me
and they ask me
if they were admitted by mistake or they
they feel like how is it that they got
admitted
and um
you know to me that says a couple things
number one um i mean i love the mit
students and and
there's a real humbleness uh to the
group that um you know they don't have
this over-inflated view of who they are
but i think also they recognize that
um they're just regular
students uh they're not perfect uh they
see their own flaws
um
and um and we we don't admit perfect
people
uh they don't exist out there
um
everyone has flaws and and that's fine
and uh we're not looking for that
perfect
applicant that perfect student because
they don't exist out there and um
you know i think that if students could
relax a little bit more
and just
focus on
doing the things that are most
interesting to them with as much energy
and enthusiasm as they can
and not to forget that they are family
members and community members and they
need to pay attention
to being good contributing members uh to
their family and their communities
um in pursuit of something else they
can't give that piece of it up
um because we're looking for all of that
and i think if students could just relax
a little bit
and not try to make themselves into the
perfect applicant
but just to be the best person they can
be
and let the applications flow
from that
i think students would have a much
better experience in high school and and
ultimately the world would be a better
place
you know and for anyone who doesn't
believe stu you know i'll even use my
own personal example uh as kind of a
case in point uh where uh you know many
people know that i was an undergrad at
mit and
you know i went to a school that had
never sent anyone to mit
i was somewhat naive about the process
but i did just kind of very
authentically put my best foot forward
it looks like i'm clipping up a little
bit my internet might be acting a little
bit shady my apologies
but that um you know i remember after i
had applied i had met some kids who went
to some of the fancy schools at a math
competition and they almost laughed at
me when they found out that i was
applying to mit because my school was
just kind of completely off the radar
type of place
and i was actually frankly very
intimidated by them because when they
told me how many who had applied from
their very fancy school in the past and
maybe hadn't got in i was like oh i
guess i was naive about this process
but uh
only later when i did get in and i kind
of reflected about the process it's
exactly what stu was describing a lot of
you know
a lot of those other applicants were
kind of engineered applicants and i
think uh whoever your predecessors were
stu uh you know kind of spotted that
while they were looking for you know i
don't want to make it sound like they
were you know they did a great decision
admitting me i wouldn't even ask y'all
whether i was a mistake
but but but i i do i do see that for
real uh that people's perceptions before
college and then what you see there what
admissions admissions officers are
telling the the reality
now a related question to that you know
obviously i had one you know someone
asked me what was my experience at mit
look i had a wonderful experience at mit
my uh i met my wife there many of my
best friends some of my best memories i
still have very positive dreams still of
times that i'm at my you know sometimes
i forgot to drop a class and that kind
of was a stressful dream uh but but i
had very positive experience there so i
couldn't endorse it more highly but what
do you say to folks you know there's
also this sense of like name brandism oh
i've got to go to an mit i've got to go
to harvard i've got to go to a stanford
otherwise you know
it's the end of the world what do you
tell
that to families or students who are
feeling that type of anxiety
yeah
um again this is where i feel like
students would do well
to just think about not think of
themselves as college applicants first
but just to think of themselves as
students and community members first and
then let the
college admissions process
fall where it may
because the reality is
that um
you know if mit is a great place
it's not a great place because
uh
you know from up on high it's been
deemed that you know mit is this magical
place it's only a great place because
the people
that are there
and and and that the students and the
faculty and the staff that are there
they make it so
and so if you're a great student
you can go anywhere
and have a great experience and make
that place just as magical and great
um i i it's really true that um
you know college is what you make it and
any college in the u.s has
more opportunity than any one student
can possibly take advantage of
and um so so students can thrive
wherever they go to school if they find
a place that they feel like really fits
the style and the environment that they
want to learn
and any student who takes advantage at
any college is going to be successful
and um you don't need to go to an mit
or you know another name brand college
you just have to cultivate yourself
as someone who's going to engage
wherever you go
and that's how you build a successful
life
now that completely resonates a lot of
what we've talked about at this live
stream before is kind of what you put
out the energy you put out is kind of
what you experience and you know i even
gave the example i think i've given this
on this live stream before when i was in
business school
you know i went with some stereotypes of
business school but then when i got
there you know i was kind of open-minded
about things i was very vulnerable open
to folks i was like oh they're just like
that they're very open and vulnerable to
me and they care more about friendships
than you know in some ways being
competitive but then i remember meeting
someone who's like you know can you
believe this place how competitive
everyone is i can't trust anyone here
and i was just like are you on a in a
different universe we're sharing the
same air but i think i didn't tell him
but i was like yeah i think you're
projecting that
yeah i completely agree you can go
anywhere and have an amazing experience
and and you can go anywhere and have a
horrible one and it's not always your
fault obviously like i'm not going to
say like everything that happens to you
is like what you're projecting but a lot
of that
a lot whatever the context is can often
be shaped by what you're projecting into
it yep
absolutely
so stu any any final on my internet
connection looks my apologies it looks
like it's falling apart and i also have
a toothache i feel like blaming my tooth
on the somehow for all of this seeming
to make my my whole life pretty i
shouldn't project onto my tooth i should
have an open mind
but it's teaching me something but stu
any final thoughts you know like what
let me ask i'll finish with a big
question what do you think are going to
be the lasting implications on
admissions on how people view college
and um how colleges might change because
of all of this
well i think we're learning a lot uh
we're forced to learn a lot because
we're doing things in new mode right now
um and
i think any time you're forced to make
changes you learn a lot and i think
ultimately when we get back to whatever
that new normal is
i hope it's not exactly the way it was
in the past i hope there are things that
we can take with us
that that go forward i you know think
about certainly
online learning is one um a way that i
think we're going to learn a lot about
it and um
perhaps take hybrid learning into the
future as well i mean khan academy a
great example of uh
an exceptional online learning
experience
and um
so so so it is possible to do that and i
think if we can take that forward into
the universities we can understand what
matters most um and and optimize what
matters most and i guess that's really
my final thought is you know in the
pandemic
uh
colleges and universities and students
and uh we're all thinking about how to
take care of ourselves and the people
around us as the absolute top priority
and i hope that when we do get back to
the other side of this pandemic
that those values remain that we think
about how can we take care of ourselves
and the people around us as a top
priority
and and not get caught up we call about
getting caught up in
engineering as the uh engineering
oneself as the perfect applicant and and
all these other things that
are just sort of noise in the system and
um i hope we can all remember really uh
what matters most
and um
take that with us uh when we get to the
other side of this pandemic
no thanks for that that's super helpful
and stu's thanks for thank you for for
being part of this and um and i'm sure
that there's a lot of tough issues that
y'all are working through but it sounds
like you'll have a good handle on it
so thanks for joining
great thanks al great to see you and
appreciate
everyone who's watching as well good
luck with everyone be well
thank you
so thanks everyone uh for joining this
live stream my apologies my internet is
breaking up and if if i haven't been at
the top of my game i'm i'm having a
horrible a toothache right now uh and so
i might have to do some covid safe uh
emergency dental uh type type of thing
so which wish me luck um
but uh you know i thought it was a
fascinating conversation i think you
know the biggest takeaway i think from
stu is
and maybe the coveted crisis is there's
a lot of things that we take very very
seriously in our life and it creates
kind of this artificial stress in our
minds that only humans you know other
other mammals don't think about like oh
if i have to go to this college and i
need this score and all that and to some
degree you know we have a lot of good
things as humans like you know
air conditioners and you know sometimes
computers and things like that but like
we oftentimes create our own stresses in
our brain brain and you know the the the
real takeaway is
if you take that away and you just be
your authentic self and you just always
put one foot in front of the other and
just try to make do of what you have as
i've quoted frozen two in the past do
the next right thing then not only will
you probably be enjoying life more but
probably other people will will will
want you to be part of their community
or or gravitate to you so it's a it's a
win-win so with that uh thanks for
joining and i i believe tomorrow we're
going to have tom friedman if i saw the
calendar correctly either tomorrow or in
the near future so that's going to be a
really interesting conversation and
hopefully by tomorrow i will have my
actually i think my appointment is right
after this so my tooth will probably be
hurting even more uh but i look forward
to seeing all of y'all on tomorrow's
live stream
you